how's it goin brass mana mana purple
welcome back we got two more episodes of
this if you're watching you got two more
hours with me oh you're so [ __ ]
Treecko oh my god I forgot Treecko are
you okay no he's not he's clearly not we
got to save him no this time it actually
looks oh [ __ ] this is bad this every
time I say this every time but every
time I come back from playing this game
for a while it looks so pretty I want to
play this game on my playstation pro
thank you place there's room for sending
me one by the way I haven't plugged it
in yet but I have a lot of places I
noise tough problem to hear him oh so
the whole thing collapsed while we were
trying desperately trying to make it
through clearly wasn't gonna work again
I don't know why we even tried to go
through a [ __ ] mining game or
whatever why would I go here
no no not now I don't have time for you
guys
[ __ ] decide what guy look different god
I hate these I want to know the story
behind them and like why do they exist
cuz they're just [ __ ] I think I have
to push them off right
stop using jiu-jitsu you goddamn Dorota
nurse
holy [ __ ] drink oh yeah down get him
just like you see on there when on the
Box are kinda I'm so glad they're just
sleeping there you go
I want speak de Beckenham oh my god I
gotta jump up on him and calming down
what all right
you're gonna hurt you don't want that
right
look how horny is now get it
okay hey he's feisty
look dumbest [ __ ] Jesus I didn't mean
to jump down there okay he's going he's
going I wasn't ready but [ __ ] it [ __ ] if
I'm ready
I'll we're back on the bridge the weird
I was looking for each oh my god I
really kind of I was thinking a lot
about this game yesterday and how it
compares to his predecessor the ICO and
my god
but you did it in okay you better oh
[ __ ] oh no there's gonna be the mirrors
by the end of this Oh No Rico
you're just gonna have to face your fear
spotty okay it's stable for now the game
is just so incredible but it it's taken
out of it because of the wonkiness okay
and it's it's such a shame you know it's
it's like the game had so much pressure
to come out that it almost got rushed
into some sense I don't why did I jump
off I just saw that I could jump down
sound like is he just gonna [ __ ]
destroy these now I'd be like hell yeah
that's character development right look
at strigas butthole why do I keep
reference item figures on what happen
like it
I like it I like one bit okay it's just
jacksepticeye I know me too
let's go [ __ ] em great I'm stuck now
[ __ ] ass how would I get up I don't see
it I don't see it what I'm supposed to
be doing maybe walk across here that
would sort of make sense yeah got it
okay well I guess we just leave Treecko
it's been a it's been a fun journey it's
just a tower that we saw in the
beginning perhaps because it seems like
we're much higher enough well how about
that we're almost dead what a national
puzzle climbing trying to write the end
do we go back or I like how different
this temple looks it's almost like it's
older than the other ones you see
comparing them like more corroded maybe
that's a word I don't know but I want to
know the story the game is telling me to
hang shut up game that's right we don't
follow the rules not on this channel I
bet jacksepticeye would hang
here's where you need to hang that's
fine I'll hang damn look at that scenery
so pretty mind god it's breathtaking so
the whole structure is covered by that
wall we if you saw the cutscene a nice
episode wearing this kind of like
cylinder looking thing the only way to
enter is through air that's why there's
no people treecko's like hey why did you
leave me maybe I should have helped him
maybe I'm progressing right now like I'm
looking at the [ __ ] eyes I don't know
I just okay I guess I'll just keep going
maybe they're such button to destroy
those later I mean it looked like I
could just push them aside but then
again if we had trigger with us right
now it'd probably look a bit different
dude this does not look comfortable I'm
stuck hey remember when I said this game
was wonky this is what I was talking
about cuz now I have to kill myself
and that's kind of annoying
[Music]
ah
they keep escaping it's it's slippies
food uh hate locust you know at least if
I fall there's an epic epic way down
this part is so weird I keep getting
stuck okay here we go we're back in
action
yeah whoa that's a shittiest scream I've
ever [ __ ] hard go up go up late yeah
yeah [ __ ] how how did I do that
four [ __ ] legs went through my [ __ ]
[Music]
okay we did it
[ __ ] yeah oh my god there's more oh I'm
sweating I'm sweating profoundly Jesus
Christ this much sweat that's never left
the human body before nice one Hey look
we're back at that bridge it's so
annoying cuz the first part is so
[ __ ] slow and then you have to do
this really intense jumps I'm really
nervous cuz I really don't I really ah
[ __ ] okay and like any small mistake
clearly counts
towards failure this is a this is the
jump I failed last time
oh just [ __ ] your hood fur that's all we
do it oh I thought we'd do it on the
Porta Potty ah
I bet jacquard died like 60 million
times yeah I couldn't just say like
three or four sixty million times okay
we got this it's time to get real [ __ ]
serious all right let's go upstairs I
think we have to go all the way around
this what am i doing I don't know either
mm-hmm cut the [ __ ] man I'm sweating my
nuts off sitting here the Sun I don't
like these eyes and I don't like you I
mean I love you I love you so much
[Music]
what a [ __ ] am I looking at here huh if
you just could jump a little longer this
you want to save everyone a big [ __ ]
problem oh I don't like them don't like
them don't like them
[Music]
this is like a [ __ ] army of them
Wow how are they this many go away get
away get away now gurgling are you God
well there's nothing I try no not bad if
I'm [ __ ] well oh whoa no I got you
fam no problem
I face my biggest fear I'm Philip
oh [ __ ] we don't have a lot of options
left now
I really thought we would go to the camp
well
well I don't think we can know his wings
grew its wings grew its buy it out not
very great not very great at it
they're not only grown
I mean literally we just have to wait
for his wings to
I'm guessing I go down here hang in
there Jericho I'm starting to think I
wasn't supposed to go with the tail
option but yep definitely why do I suck
so much penis can you answer me that
right now because I'm mad at the gate
okay well oh I was supposed to go there
[ __ ]
there's a lever right there [ __ ] No
hey Katie somebody come on hang in buddy
no no no now he's in the bottom one [ __ ]
we gotta hurry up real fast cuz he's
real [ __ ] Santa I know what he eats
it's way too much of that [ __ ] what do i
do what do I guess I can mention the
other one hang in buddy you shut the
[ __ ] up
sorry Oh guess I'm not helping right now
oh he looks so sad
no I want to give this so bad my life
depends on this all I care about right
now god dammit stop twitching work on
your [ __ ] triceps huh hanging hanging
play ah Jesus Shay I'm coming I'm coming
I'm going no no no not again
are you serious oh thank god
get it don't worry about me go to Italy
this happen well [ __ ] hey buddy how you
doing hey it's me how you going bounce
hey high five don't worry I'll catch I
swear to God I will actually I'm really
good gotcha how am i stalking where
they're saying mmm oh gosh it awesome
[Music]
look at me like oh these are kill you
too you know a tree corner again a
little what I say we got a tower in fire
okay
oh I can't wait to fly and trigger it's
gonna be amazing it's gonna be the
highlight of my life right now and right
now I'm here flying I'm Treecko
you know cuddling Treecko sexing Treecko
flying Treecko wait what do I think
I'm not I'm not your dad
it's okay freak oh I'm fine I would
stand but I don't understand what you're
saying but pretty tricky okay you're
[ __ ]
right okay mmm
yeah oh no I need trigger jesus [ __ ]
christ what's the hurry
I'm dying you know been through a lot
okay that's great okay don't worry about
me hanging on your eyeball nails that
now let's do another jump where are we
right now it's like we're in the sky
where does he going okay he went for
that one
it's cool he's using his wings now dude
that seemed a lil unnecessary but I
appreciate the call back look at the
birds down in the distance it's so
[ __ ] cool
okay so now that's where we crashed
before isn't it
[ __ ] we [ __ ] this place uh we have a
tendency we'll keep walking in circles
Rico I don't know what I feel about that
dude when my horns go out and my wings
go out people go it's gonna be [ __ ]
awesome
well did he just jump randomly cuz he
didn't know where
follow me Treecko look there's a thing
around the edge you [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
look at that I do it pretty well I'd do
it for a while wait where is he I mean
where is he oh hey look at that we
managed to progress in the game things
that should take two seconds take three
hours I am stuck now in there akia come
on there's a great I canyon right [ __ ]
oh there's more soldiers in here I
really need you in here buddy there you
go okay finally [ __ ] me don't just go
he's not doing it you got it baby you've
got it now kill kill kill him oh [ __ ]
they got one of those kill oh [ __ ] you
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] hurt how did that even
hit there
ha smack my [ __ ] up that's what I'm
talking he seems to calm down faster now
that's pretty cool oh my god what the
[ __ ] is G SAS you're insane ok now he
doesn't care anymore
ok well awesome great whole I'm glad the
whole game just changed what the [ __ ]
did he not see it what the hell was that
huh
what the hell I don't understand I'm
done and I'm done I am just gonna push
you off we're gonna be dead
oh [ __ ] he's scared of it okay well if
we push it as far away as possible maybe
we can jam
oh there's a lover I see a lever
actually a lever do you see that lever I
see that well that's who care of that
[ __ ] and backup thank you very much okay
that was [ __ ] awesome that was
awesome oh oh oh no oh oh it's evil
sorry no well it's time to
and I've got an arm you watch out little
boy I do not like you we're not product
I tear it away from it you stay ah I
won't kill you
gosh ah [ __ ] I'm not very good at this
it's not fair he has an armor do
something no [ __ ] you let go of me
oh my god yes
help him how do we help him drink oh my
oh no no no [ __ ] you don't [ __ ] touch
me what do I do
[ __ ] another another one ah for my brows
for my brother [ __ ] that didn't what did
that do okay let's spit
I got you Pam stop [ __ ] with my
broski oh [ __ ] they keep throwing new
ones what do i do all I got was that
thing and I one thing I do okay
screeches tail wait first I'll fab it up
babban a beep boo but ever this might
sting a little bit
you [ __ ] [ __ ] don't [ __ ] hurt
my bro
this is what happens when you mess with
the bro
that's fine are you ready hey ass [ __ ]
got him got him oh [ __ ] he's pissed at
you
don't touch my box
god oh no [ __ ] [ __ ] it keep okay it
keeps going down huh
Treecko
and we go in here no McCain
that's a bit high I do it for my bro
[ __ ] ow oh here we go
that might actually way okay am I
supposed to get the chain [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's it okay out-trick oh hang in
there we'll new comic john i'm fighting
an epic battle man he doesn't know I'm
here
come on climb that chain dog climb it
fast deep come I don't know how many
Spears the trigger can handle okay
this is bad
get up get up Treecko Treecko if you can
hear me get the [ __ ] out out of the way
cuz it's about to move [ __ ] here we go
we go we go bye bye
okay oh my god did I hit him Oh No who
do you hate Treecko
he lost his armor go down damn it he
returned
so did the speargun no-spray guys still
throw Spears [ __ ] [ __ ] spray guy
[Music]
trigger I'm coming
[ __ ] you
Treecko no oh hey you spit out the
weight he had a medallion all along it's
gonna be okay
[Music]
don't worry trigger I'll be right back
I'm gonna get your favorite snack oh
[ __ ]
yeah I remember trust me
emember
get some at that man relates to Jess
Draco it's it's a miracle I got your
drugs everything's gonna be fine and
you'll feed me and my belly
nom-nom-nom
[Music]
oops no I'm trying to grab the bottle
but he jumps up on three boys please
I'm starving well he still hasn't eaten
it trigger you have to eat I need you to
eat one of these that's okay so you had
to hold it for him okay
[Music]
hey you good good boy another one it's
your favorite I got to this does not
look comfortable I think I saw one more
severe what do we have here a chain nice
I don't know where this goes
but we're climbing it baby you got that
right that's right all right climb that
chain
yeah there's butterflies here so there's
bound to be a cake I really want to try
one of the cakes see what it tastes like
you know what happened here their keg
here has anyone seen a cake [ __ ] me I
don't see a keg [ __ ] oh I see of course
excuse his little tail very dangerous oh
my god that was so close Jesus Christ
hey hey two more awesome okay watch
watch out down there
you're [ __ ] idiot one nailed it you
did it you sure did it I thought maybe I
couldn't get her as I'm [ __ ] I don't
know okay [ __ ]
oh okay Hideo great more obstacles in
the [ __ ] way look what I found
it's your favorite no no [ __ ] way
you have four of them what is th mess
[ __ ] it's for you
there you go now we just have to cut
okano where's the camera going is he
coming back
I farted is it oh is it all or is it
just beginning
I want to go snowboarding but I don't
know how to adorbs fun fantastically
cute
I hate that either guy it's an [ __ ]
why would he do that
Oh Tommy sit on you eat there harder
cuss to Oh easy deep just like the game
began and we have another dream okay
interesting
no it just turned into oh they're so
cute they're sleeping
that thing is totally ruined the guts
thank you
he feels better
not 100% for it's like a bad hangover
I've had worse
[Music]
hell yeah we're gonna make it back up
but in the next episode which will be
the final let me double-check that okay
I'll play a little bit more okay drink
oh let's go [ __ ] kick some ass boy no
more okay yeah all right we're going
this way I mean y'all ready oh yeah
Gaudio oh my god
calm down dude let's get their fool
caddy
I like being lower feel safer no way I
like that we fell down
okay he started moving just by himself
hey we're back here that was fast like I
just gonna wash it off [ __ ] we got a
cold rain bas gonna be real pissed [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you can suck a dick you know what let's
fry him you [ __ ] dead mate ah [ __ ] no
no we do not do that come on that would
have been fun come on
I don't like you you look like a mamas
butthole and your date he doesn't okay
fine ha ha ha
what was that so glitchy not jump okay
fine I would do it one two three one two
three
0.20 state photographs got a creep what
events melody whatever the bullet get it
not a problem God that maybe ate a
little too many of the cakes they're
there
oh look there's okay yeah am I the only
one hearing this thank you hi pre Oh
more enemy yeah oh shoot oh shoot
nope miss me haha now let's jump going
all the way up trick Oh show me all your
tricks let's go all the way up maybe all
the way job oh oh oh nice double jump
all the way across the sky don't look
back
we go full bucket it's so slow at these
[ __ ] I broke my leg it's fine don't
worry happens all the time
oh sorry just furball no big deal I can
ignore me okay I think we're back in
this room where we jumped in all I know
is that other Treecko son of a [ __ ]
does not have his armor anymore and
we're gonna kick his [ __ ] ass that's
why we go kick EJ's they said to me dude
you got six cakes it was four
finally I don't know why it takes so
long what a Martian ruined okay
what the hell whoa that's cool
I ruined it as well what the [ __ ] what
am I looking at Thanks
see ah what the [ __ ] camera angles I
want to see it's so pretty
Chico what are you smoking like for real
let's go back the way we came
[Music]
it's backtracking okay that's why at
least it looks different okay
[ __ ] listen somebody's Oh cuz now we
have this we can progress
whoa that's so cool
nice looks so [ __ ] epic I love the
lightning and how it changed this is why
we could go back before I wreck it it
just hit me that [ __ ] door we could
easily explode I didn't [ __ ] see it
look at that [ __ ] oh my god I'm just
gonna jump you off cuz you're some
[ __ ] [ __ ] and walking no oh God
don't freak oh [ __ ] don't eat me don't
eat me please don't don't eat me
[ __ ] he's gonna
what is he doing yeah we need to destroy
that [ __ ] thing those are like the
heart of the evil evil in streak oh yeah
grab his [ __ ] tail net yes [ __ ] that
thing I'm back I felt great
what happened look at this [ __ ] oh look
at that building oh my god you could
just [ __ ] shoot all of these piece of
[ __ ] glasses there he comes
okay maybe not just jumped in looks so
cool I'm getting really tired of the
spot I don't know am I the only one here
these parts
like I'm playing and not waiting for an
AI to respond to my command
sometimes they work so well I kind of
wish there was a just let Treecko do his
thing but instead of having to bury him
guess this is fine if he just jumps but
a lot of times it's like okay that is
cool that is very cool see it's cool
when it works this is [ __ ] awesome
actually all right what do you say we
nice nice nice another another one
that's cool so maybe now we can jump
there okay that's cool that's really
[ __ ] cool a bedsheet
grab a chair Betty oh my god how did I
limb what the [ __ ] was that [ __ ]
he was ready to jump regardless if I was
on or not so pretty I love this light oh
that's a cool job I never get tired of
these when they actually work this looks
dangerous it's gonna break so cool
look at this [ __ ] game if it would
work I'm calming jeez how's he doing
I love how she shoots like that now it's
so cool this works I'll be happy
9 noise hey you almost kill me
cool very cool literally anywhere you
like I don't care at this point
thank you very cool as well thank you
you're in a role Treecko you got this
now what I don't know either look at
that [ __ ] there's nothing maybe it's up
to me to climb around open the gate
yeah that might that's probably okay I
got this no problem I've done this good
don't die
these are so safe right I mean they'd be
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
how long am I gonna fly Jesus
for [ __ ] sake I'm out I'm [ __ ] out
what a [ __ ] range episode Jesus Christ
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll see in the
next episode
you